sommes nous tous des mutants ça c'est la
grosse question alors nous sommes tous
des mutants parce que on a tous des
nouvelles mutations c'est à dire que
chaque individu sur la planète à 70
nouvelles mutations
c'est à la fois très peu parce qu'il
faut bien voir l'adn effet de 3
milliards de lettres qui sont assez tg
et donc chaque individu porte 70
nouvelles mutations
c'est à dire nouvelles lettres qui sont
inchangés dans l'ensemble du génome donc
70 sur 3 milliards
c'est pas grand chose d'un autre côté
ces mutations c'est ça qui fait
l'évolution c'est ça qui fait qu'on est
devenue mme ces mutations c'est ça la
source de diversité sur laquelle après
on peut avoir de la sélection parce que
de temps en temps certaines de ces
mutations sont intéressantes on dit
avantageuse et vont être sélectionnés
vont se répandre dans la population à
travers les descendants et c'est ça qui
fait l'évolution de tout être vivant et
en particulier des humains donc oui nous
sommes tous des mutants et tant mieux
la direction du génome humain ben c'est
très difficile à dire il faudrait une
boule de cristal 1
tout ce qu'on sait c'est que à l'heure
actuelle avec les mélanges entre des
individus qui viennent de d'endroits
très différents et donc qui ont des
apparences physiques différentes avec de
plus en plus de mélange on va voir
émerger entre guillemets des nouveaux on
dit phénotype c'est à dire des nouvelles
apparences par exemple on peut très bien
imaginer que vous rencontriez dans 50
ans un individu qui a une une figure
plutôt asiatique a une couleur de peau
noire qui a les yeux bleus qui a les
cheveux roux
m
bon moment